he was pulling my hip and I was swinging
away to sell the car made contact with
him
um as you know I'm not one to apologize
for things I meant to do but I do
apologize to you sir
um because I didn't intend to hit them
uh I sell calls with my arms I don't
fall to sell a call I don't not a
Flopper so I was just selling the car
because he was grabbing me and pulling
my HP back so I spun away and
unfortunately I hit him and so like I
said I apologize to you SEF I've said
before any replay you know if I go look
at every replay of everything um a
replay is that it's never going to look
good you know but like I said I know my
intentions my intentions were to sell
the call
um and you know I also don't think I'm
accurate enough puncher to do a full 360
and and connect with someone